PROFESSOR: So let's
do an example where
we can calculate
from the beginning
to the end everything.
Now, you have to get
accustomed to the idea of even
though you can
calculate everything,
your formulas that you get
sometimes are a little big.
And you look at them
and they may not
tell you too much unless you
plot them with a computer.
So we push the calculations
to some degree,
and then at some
point, we decide
to plot things using a
computer and get some insight
on what's happening.
So here's the example.
We have a potential up
to distance, a, to 0.
The wall is always there, and
this number is minus v naught.
So it's a well,
a potential well.
And we are producing energy.
Eigenstates are coming here.
And the question now is to
really calculate the solution
so that we can really
calculate the phase shift.
We know how the
solutions should read,
but unless you do
a real calculation,
you cannot get the phase shift.
So that's what we want to do.
So for that, we have to solve
the Schrodinger equation.
Psi of x is equal to what?
Well, there's a discontinuity.
So we probably have to write
an answer in which we'll
have a solution in one piece and
a solution in the other piece.
But then we say, oh,
we wrote the solution
in the outside piece already.
It is known.
It's always the same.
It's universal.
I don't have to think.
I just write this.
E to the i delta.
I don't know what
delta is, but that's
the answer, E to the i delta
sine kx plus delta should
be the solution for
x greater than a.
You know if you were
not using that answer,
it has all the
relevant information
for the problem, time
delays, everything,
you would simply write
some superposition of E
to the i kx and E to the minus
i kx with two coefficients.
On the other hand, here, we
will have, again, a wave.
Now, it could be maybe
an E to the i kx or E
to the minus i kx.
Neither one is very good
because the wave function
must vanish at x equals 0.
And in fact, the k that
represents the kinetic energy
here, k is always related to
E by the standard quantity,
k squared equal to mE
over h squared or E equal
the famous formula.
On the other hand, there
is a different k here
because you have
different kinetic energy.
There must be a k prime here,
which is 2m E plus v naught.
That's a total kinetic
energy over h squared.
And yes, the solutions
could be E to the ik prime
x equal to minus ik
prime x minus ik prime x,
but since they must vanish at
0, should be a sine function.
So the only thing
we can have here
is a sine of k prime x for x
less than a and a coefficient.
We didn't put the additional
normalization here.
We don't want to put
that, but then we
must put the number here,
so I'll put it here.
That's the answer, and
that's k and k prime.
Now we have boundary
conditions that x equals a.
So psi continues at x equals a.
What does it give you?
It gives you a sine of ka
is equal to E to the i delta
sine of ka plus delta.
And psi prime continues
at x equals a will give me
ka cosine ka equal--
I have primes missing;
I'm sorry, primes--
equals k E to the i delta
cosine ka plus delta.
What do we care for?
Basically we care for delta.
That's what we want to find
out because delta tells us
all about the physics
of the scattering.
It tells us about the scattering
amplitude, sine squared delta.
It tells us about the time
delay, and let's calculate it.
Well, one way to
calculate it is to take
a ratio of these two
equations so that you get rid
of the a constant.
So from that side
of the equation,
you get k cotangent
of ka plus delta
is equal to k prime
cotangent of k prime a.
Or cotangent of ka plus
delta is k prime over k.
We'll erase this.
And now you can do two things.
You can display some
trigonometric wizardry,
or you say, OK, delta is arc
cotangent of this minus ka.
That is OK, but it's not ideal.
It's better to do a little bit
of trigonometric identities.
And the identity
that is relevant
is the identity for cotangent of
a plus b is cot a cot b minus 1
over cot a plus cot b.
So from here, you have
that this expression
is cot ka cot delta minus 1
over cot ka plus cot delta.
And now, equating left-hand
side to this right-hand side,
you can solve for
cotangent of delta.
So cotangent of delta
can be solved for--
and here is the answer.
Cot delta is equal to tan
ka plus k prime over k cot k
prime a over 1 minus k prime
over k cot k prime a tan ka.
Now, who would box such
a complicated equation?
Well, it can't be
simplified any more.
Sorry.
That's the best we can do.